hello everyone and welcome to round two
of the opera euro rapid tournament it's
magnus carlsen versus levin aaron and in
the first game magnus lost like we've
seen in the previous video whereas 11
defeated none other than being lyran and
here
the two of them face off against each
other and it's uh well it's again quite
the game so without further ado let's
check it out and we're gonna
uh maybe maybe tomorrow morning when i
wake up we're gonna discuss a bit more
about the tournament uh
what is it who's playing because there
are a lot of players and whatnot
but now let's just focus on the game so
magnus with the white pieces opens with
the d4
and he really would enjoy a nice win to
get back into the tournament we have
knight to f6 by 11
c4 we have e6 knight to f3 and d5 and of
course we have the queen's gambit
declined
uh we have knights to c3 and bishop to
b4 going for the ragosan defense
captures on d5 e captures and bishop to
g5 this is
carlson's go-to line with h6 bishop to
h4
and here 11 castles uh we have e3
so this has all been played before
bishop to f5 now
just uh eyeing that d3 square we're
waiting to see where carlson will
develop the light square bishop
and now while you could play a few moves
here let's say a3 queen b3 bishop to d3
and so on knight e5 also magnus goes for
bishop to d3 and
immediately attacks 11 bishop on f5
uh we have bishop characters queen
captures and now uh
knight b to d7 uh we have queen to b5 by
magnus now
uh putting pressure on the b7 pawn and
the knight so 11 just captures it
bishop captures b captures and now
knight to b6
getting rid of rid of the threats and
here uh there are some games where c6
was played but here
uh magnus goes for knight to d2 and it
is as of move
uh 12 that we have a completely new game
so let's see how lemon deals with this
uh first he goes queen to d7 because you
can see that
in the position uh there's a a lot of
a lot of potential uh and uh carlson is
the one who will be pushing he still
hasn't castled he might be
uh uh starting to push those points on
the king side and eleven wants to
trade off the queen so here queen to d7
the new move
uh queen captures on d7 knight f
captures on d7 you don't want to allow
whites to mess up your pawn structure so
knight captures but okay you could have
captured with this knight and then this
knight is defended so i guess it works
uh and
a4 magnus now wants to dislodge this
knight from b6 and 11 defense with
a5 uh king to e2 and now
rook f2 e8 and here just rook h to b1 by
magnus and now uh
magnus will simply bring the rook to b5
play
rook a to b1 and try and create some
sort of uh threats along the b
file whereas it's going to be a bit more
complicated for lemon to activate his
pieces so he here he tries with
rook to e6 and okay bishop to g3
and now c5 so not the pawn will no
longer be a target and you are attacking
white strong center
uh rook to b5 putting more pressure on
the c5 pawn
and now even c for deciding to keep
the center closed sorry about that just
a second
oh
um
oh sorry about that it was not the
mailman but it was the pizza guy
uh so c4 keeping the position closed in
the center
and now bishop to c7 now magnus wants to
mount the pressure on this knight on b6
he's going to play rook 8 to b1
and it's not going to be easy for black
to defend this so here the immediate
rook to c6 he says okay let's see what
you intend to do with the bishop either
move the bishop or trade now so i can
also
just uh capture back and here magnus
goes for it bishop captures on b6
knight captures on b6 and now uh
g4 he just starts grabbing more space on
the king side it's not as if this knight
is going anywhere
this pawn is nicely defended and that's
why 11 wanted to have his knight on b6
so magnus cannot just play rook 8 to b1
because he will lose the a pawn and then
levon gets his own past a pawn
so here came to f8 we are in the end
game so of course you must
improve the activity of your king we
have h4 by magnus and the king to e8 now
and now magnus goes e4 so here you
either trade or you allow magnus to push
e5 but
uh trading here isn't all that great uh
not because of knight captures but
rather d5 is even more
uh dangerous because now the rook will
not be able to keep an eye on the knight
so whatever you do here
you're going to play rook to d6 now
comes knight captures on e4
attacks uh your rook here and now you
can
move the rook somewhere here but then
for example h5
and uh it is a fun line rook rook g6 h5
now
uh kicks away the rook from the defense
of the knight here but you play rook
captures in g4
attack this night but it's not a problem
knight d6 check king d7 and only now
rook captures king to c7 attacking both
the knight and the rook and only now
rook 8 to b1
and the white is up a piece so this is
what carlson has in mind when he plays
e4
so rook to d8 by 11 and now
e5 as planned we have f6 trying to
challenge that
pawn here and now f4 uh we have
g5 by 11 and if you don't try this
breakthrough with the g5 you're not
really going to have a lot of fun
playing this is
just going to be white mounting the
position forever so here
g5 and magnus just trades h captures h
captures and
f5 now preparing to create a monster
pass pawn here
so 11 trades once but now the captures
and again
two connected pass pawns are just uh not
not going to be easy to defend
so here 11 finds d4 it's very very
sneaky as it creates a past c
pawn but magnus says uh first i'm just
going to play
rook the h1 and now i'm gonna have these
pawns uh here i'm gonna play rook to h8
rook to h7 check
it's gonna be very hard for you to
defend this so here d captures on c3 now
the pass pawn is very close but
knights the e for now a knight to f6
check could be deadly
uh so here c2 and now first
e6 not even allowing this rook to
sacrifice itself for the knight so
magnus just blocks it off with e6
and now what do you play here now rook
to h8 will we
will be super strong so here rook to d4
first going after the knight here
but now just rook to e5 uh or you could
go for some rook to h8
action you could play knight captures on
g5 but magnus goes for the com
rook to e5 and now knight to d
five by eleven uh and here comes rook
captures on d5 saying that okay if you
capture the rook just knight f6
check and i win a piece here not a
problem uh you're down tonight so
instead after rook captures on d5 we
have rook captures on e4 instead
this comes with check king to d2 and now
rook
captures on g4 but now uh ma um uh
carlsen's rook uh
brings uh goes all the way to h8 with
check
so rook h8 check king e7 and now rook to
h7
check we if you go here then just
checkmate with rook to f7 so
obviously not that so king to e8 by 11
and now comes
f6 and now all of the squares are
covered how do you prevent
checkmate uh well levin finds a very
interesting idea
pawn to c1 check and now you have to
capture the queen otherwise you're just
getting mated so king captures on c1
and now 11 is the one who goes on a
checking spree like magnus did in the
previous game against wesley so
so rogue g1 check king c2 rook g2 check
king d1
rook g1 check king to c2 and now rook
the g2 checks 11 of course would be very
happy with the repetition
but king to c3 uh with rook g3 checked
and now magnus goes for it
king d4 rook d3 check now we have king
the e5 and
rook the e3 check king to f5 and now
delivering one more check doesn't really
do anything because it's just game over
rook to h8 will be
end uh so here uh instead we have rook c
captures on e6 now that both rooks are
attacking the e6 pawn
eleven just captures it and now rook to
h8 is not checkmate
but it is uh i mean it is checkmate but
in eight
moves uh so here magnus of course played
rook to h8 check
and it was in this position that levin
aaron resigned the game on move 47 and
magnus gets his first victory in the
tournament and now
uh levels the score as he now has one
loss and one
a win the same as 11 here so it's going
to be a very eventful tournament i'm not
going to be able to cover most of the
games but that's why you have the live
coverage and you can also watch
watch that yeah so i'm just gonna cover
some of the games and then tomorrow
morning i'm gonna
uh cover those games that you you
use hashtag suggestion on uh so i'm just
gonna go go through them
uh but yeah after rookh811 resign
because after king f7
is just a very quick checkmate rook d7
check the king has no square so you have
to start giving up material
and after f captures on e7 uh this will
be game over because it's going to be a
double check from the queen and the rook
and there's no avoiding this
uh if rook f3 checked just king g4 rook
for checking captures on g5 and that's
it next movie's game over
so yeah after rook to h8 um uh 11
resigns and
magnus gets his first victory in the
tournament so we're gonna see
if this uh you know he improves his mood
and will he start uh
uh pl playing like like a world champion
should
uh so uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
dolly burleico jeffreyfiddlemd alexander
brickman mark virag and
denis ponomarenko for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the uh euro
rapid opera tournament checking up on
your one of the suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day